[music playing]
NARRATOR: At Morgan's
wind-pummeled homestead
in the great Alaska Range--
It's starting to sleet.
NARRATOR: --there's a
storm brewing above.
MARGARET: Hey, Morgan.
What's that?
NARRATOR: And another below.
MORGAN: There's
water in the cellar?
Yeah.
Aw, no.
[bleep] OK, I'll be down as
soon as I get this finished.
God damnit.
MARGARET: Oh, yeah.
We got quite a bit.
NARRATOR: The root cellar
beneath the cabin floor
holds their only
supply of potatoes
and remaining vegetables,
along with the seeds
they'll plant in the spring.
MARGARET: We need
to take everything
out and kind of figure out
a way to deal with this.
Oh, gosh.
NARRATOR: Water damage can
devastate six months' worth
of food in a matter of days.
MARGARET: They're all
gonna rot in there.
And that would really
be unfortunate.
Hoo.
Well, there's definitely some
water on that valuable seed.
So that's gonna have to get gone
through and the bag dried out.
NARRATOR: Losing the food cache
would force Morgan and Margaret
to rely solely on protein.
So-- oh, that one's wet.
Ugh.
Yeah.
I'm gonna work on this and hold
all the vegetables out really
quickly here.
Dry off the vegetables, and
make sure everything is OK.
[wind whistling]
MORGAN: We almost made it
without weather coming in,
but now it's definitely
here, and started
picking up snow and sleet.
I think it's turning to rain.
Just gonna get out there and
get this ridge cap on so water
doesn't get in
underneath the roofing.
NARRATOR: The ridge cap connects
the two sides of the roof
at its peak, 20 feet up.
--service.
Razor sharp along
the new cut edge.
Gotta be real careful with it.
[music playing]
Just a few more screws.
[machine whirring]
All right.
It's all buttoned down.
We can get off of
here now, and go see
what's going on in the cellar.
I hope it's not too bad.
Oh, wow.
NARRATOR: Morgan and Margaret's
most critical food supply
is under siege.
MORGAN: Looks like you're
waist deep in the cellar there.
MARGARET: Yes, I am.
We got lots of water down there.
It's a bad deal.
We've got to take
care of that and get
these vegetables into a safe
spot so the rot doesn't spread.
Oh, boy.
Well, I will go get
a bucket and shovel
that will fit down in there,
and I'll dig a sump hole.
I'm gonna climb down in
there and do some dirty work
and dig a sump.
Basically what that
means, I'm just
gonna dig a narrow,
deep hole that all
the water can run into, and
hopefully drain away into soil.
MARGARET: So I'm going
through all of our potatoes.
A lot of these
potatoes are dirty.
You don't want to wash the
dirt off of your root crops,
and it helps keep
them a little bit.
And I'm putting
these in paper bags
because the paper bags
will allow the potatoes
to dry out pretty quickly.
We're gonna toss the
rest of this batch.
Put that outside for now.
Nothing smells worse
than rotten potatoes.
MORGAN: All right,
that should be good.
It's down into a
nice gravelly soil.
It should drain really well.
MARGARET: And if you want
to get some boards, too,
that would be nice
to lay some boards
down there to just
elevate things
off the ground a little bit.
You bet.
MARGARET: Kind of
makes it a little bit
of a makeshift floor.
It's just to give the
vegetables a little bit
of elevation over any water
that might continue to come in.
All right.
I'm ready to put all these
back down on the slabs.
You want me to move
any of the heavy stuff?
MARGARET: Yeah, would you
actually do the big tots?
You bet, yeah.
Everything looks good.
And there's actually
surprisingly little loss.
Not too much rot, not too
many vegetables that went bad.
And hopefully they'll be
safe from any more moisture
that's gonna come in here.
Come spring and summer,
when the ground's thawed,
we'll just have to
improve the drainage
on the back side of the house
so this doesn't happen again.
[music playing]
All right, cool.
It's nice to have all
that stuff organized, too.
Is that everything?
MARGARET: Yes.
MORGAN: OK.
Quite a day.
It's like the whole
house was coming apart.
I mean, when it rains, it pours.
But we got both of
them nipped in the bud
before they could
get out of hand.
The list of things to
do is never-ending,
but we're just here to stay.
[wind whistling]